buscan defender sus derechos
cientos de indígenas de brasil acampan a
las afueras de los ministerios del
gobierno como forma de protesta
existe hoy varios hoy hay varios
proyectos de ley en el parlamento que
abren los territorios indígenas a la
minería por lo que la ley 191 de hoy
refuerza estos avances dentro de
nuestros territorios y este acto aquí es
para decir que no que estos proyectos no
pueden seguir adelante
el proyecto de ley permitiría además la
agricultura comercial y la exploración
petrolera en sus territorios la
legislación respaldada por el poderoso
lobby agrícola también permitiría la
construcción de presas hidroeléctricas
en tierras indígenas más de 200 tribus
quieren que el gobierno no apruebe la
legislación propuesta por el presidente
de jair bolsonaro quien dice que los
indígenas tienen demasiada tierra
desde su campaña bolsonaro dijo que si
era elegido no iba a dejar un centímetro
de tierra de marcada los pueblos
indígenas
así que desde su campaña empezó a
declararnos la guerra
en brasil el 13 por ciento es tierra de
reserva indígena protegida y el 98 por
ciento de ellas se encuentra en la
región amazónica unas 400 comunidades
indígenas siguen luchando para que se
les reconozcan sus tierras ancestrales
el campamento tierra libre que estará
hasta el 14 de abril espera la presencia
de siete mil personas esta es la mayor
movilización indígena de brasil